Je ne pouvais parler à personne et avoir une
conversation avec eux à moins qu'ils ne soient
blancs et pas seulement blancs mais blancs
et racistes nous ne pouvions pas regarder des films
d'Hollywood parce que nous pensons qu'ils sont
tous de la propagande juive nous ne pouvions pas regarder
la télévision je  Je ne pouvais pas écouter de musique qui
n'était pas de la musique raciste violente
[Musique]
Je voyais la haine comme un autre moyen d'
obtenir cette poussée d'adrénaline comme oh
je te déteste comme si c'était juste une partie de
l'habitude que j'avais il y a beaucoup  de
parallèles entre l'idéologie de l'extrémisme violent
et la toxicomanie
[Musique]
qui j'étais quand j'ai entendu de la
musique skinhead du pouvoir blanc qui était très rapide et
agressive ce que j'aime j'avais l'impression d'
être un rebelle j'aime avoir été
courageux en entrant dans cette idéologie
alors qu'en fait c'était vraiment juste une
expression de ma peur et de ma souffrance
[Musique]
à ce moment-là, j'avais perdu le compte du
nombre d'amis incarcérés, alors
ça m'a finalement frappé que si je ne
croyais pas que la mort ou la prison allait prendre
moi de ma fille de nos jours, les tatouages ​​​​que
je reçois sont pour témoigner de la
souffrance des autres et pour me rappeler que
le but de ma vie devrait être d'
aider à soulager les personnes souffrant
[Musique]
fête Kalika a tendu la main pour vraiment
demander comment quelqu'un pourrait  commettent ce genre
de violence et ma réponse était pratique
ce n'est jamais une excuse pour haïr les gens mais
c'est une raison pour laquelle la haine
vient
[Musique]
nous travaillons avec des jeunes de tous
horizons faisant des projets de service
cultivant vraiment l'unité de l'
humanité à travers des actes  de résoudre des
problèmes dans notre société et aujourd'hui je suis
très heureux de dire que j'ai des amis qui sont
noirs rouges jaunes marrons blancs Je suis une
personne de couleur en fait j'ai des couleurs
partout sur moi
[Musique]
J'ai eu plus de communication de la part
des gens  dans les groupes haineux qui cherchent des
conseils pour sortir